we have this very rigid and tight-holded
holding grip on our sense of
meanness i'm not enough i'm unlovable
i'm a beautiful with this combination of
beliefs and stories and emotions and
patterning and energetics that we've
held onto from our past we identify and
hold on to this pattern as a version of
ourselves and we think that this version
of ourselves that we have become is who
we really are and the degree to which we
hold on to
that version of danican-ness or cuteness
is the degree to which we're not free as
children we're born free you know you
look at a child they're in touch with
the divine you know we were these bright
beings we would jump on a table and sing
and shout and we were just being letting
it all hang out we pooped when we felt
like pooping we cried when we felt like
we were just being
pure essential light the light that we
were
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you very much for
watching i'm grateful for your
attendance your interests i hope that
these shows
teach you things and inspire you they
sure do that to me so speaking of today
on the show is koot blackson he's a
transformational teacher an
international speaker and an author his
newest book is out called the magic of
surrender and
we had
a deep conversation
i mean we dropped in really quick with
the human experience the law of
mirroring relationships i love having
those conversations because it's not
always very common to have conversations
about relationships so deeply but
he shared some very interesting
perspectives on relationship kut is
extremely
wise
and he has such a pure heart enjoy this
episode and be free and you'll hear at
the end but go play and thank you so
much make sure to hit subscribe hit the
thumbs up and also please let us know in
the comments uh what you liked and what
you're interested in it really helps us
to know what kind of shows that you guys
are into so we can make more of them you
know i found out about you i was um i
was at a retreat at the beginning of the
year
uh in mexico and it was
a very interesting retreat and there was
a girl there that had been to your
10 day 10 or 11
12 day bali retreat oh wow
and she was awesome she was i think she
was russian
named i think her name is nina
you remember
i know me now she's okay
blonde long black
she's intense she's amazing totally and
she was she was amazing i really
connected with her she was great and she
told me
that if i wanted to go on an amazing
retreat where if you really wanted to
know your truth if you really wanted to
dive deep
go
to one of his retreats so i started
started following you then and i get
what she's saying so like when she says
that what does that mean like what does
she what is she implying what's the
what's the situation and what why would
she say that why would she say that um
i'm known for the sort of intensity of
my work i'm just on a logistical kind of
level you know it's it's
the retreats i do are immersive in such
a way like typical retreats you go you
have a schedule
it's nine to five you know what the
itinerary is going to be uh even retreat
to like mexico or bali what have you you
go and you know
you have your seminar time and then you
have your swim time your pool time your
gym time your you know you're you're
you're hanging out at a cenote time
you're walking in the jungle time the
kind of events i do
uh i'm immersive in such a way where i
am i unplug you from everything familiar
and i take away all those places that
you typically might
hang or hold on to for a sense of
yourself and so for instance you don't
know you don't even know where the hotel
is you don't you get picked up at the
airport you don't know where you're
going you don't know
how long the days are you don't know
what the schedule is you don't know
anything about anything about anything
other than you're showing up to let's
say in this case bali and it starts on
this day it ends on this day but apart
from that you don't know when you're
going to eat i uh i unplug you from your
cell phones your ipads your internet
everything and you just show up on day
one
it's profound it's really profound i
mean we think we're free you know many
times well i'm so free but when we take
away someone's iphone and someone's you
know title and someone's makeup and
someone's clothing and you know all of
that stuff uh
all of our [ __ ] comes up and so so much
of our sense of ourselves and our sense
about freedom is based on external
factors and so my work is really
designed to unhook you from your own
patterning and patterns in an
experiential way like you can read about
stuff and i've written books but you can
read about stuff but i say information
by itself is not enough because there's
many things that we we know we should do
and we shouldn't do it most of us we've
read about it we know it most of us can
even write books about it it's our it's
it's a pattern of conditioning right
that stops us from being able to
integrate and embody it in our being in
our mental emotional psychological
psychic energetic
body so to speak and so for me it's it's
about the experiential processes that i
take people through
that that unhinge you from your pattern
and conditioning so it's an
unconditioning process
yeah so are you trying to
trigger people
or are you just trying to change
the pattern and make them more present
by not having them know what's coming
next and forcing them into
a different sort of um
mental space like where yeah i'm not
trying to necessarily like intentionally
trigger people
but but but i think when you put people
in a environment of the unfamiliar
and the unknown
naturally
uh
a lot of the unresolved fears and stuff
will tend to rise to the surface that we
have been able to hide and mask
in our tick-tock everyday lives of
routines and habits that we can you know
control and so
let's let's let me just explain it this
way
it's really you know we're so addicted
and attached to our sense of self as
this ego structure that we believe
ourselves to be i'm cool i'm nina i'm
danica i'm jennifer and this is me and
so we have this
very rigid and tight holded holding grip
on our sense of
meanness i'm not enough i'm unlovable
i'm not beautiful i'm not this i'm not
that i'm not intelligent
and so with this combination of beliefs
and stories and emotions and patterning
and energetics that we've held onto from
our past we hold on to this
we identify and hold on to this pattern
as a version of ourselves and we think
that this version of ourselves that we
have become is who we really are and the
degree to which we hold on
that version of danican-ness or cuteness
or john-ness is the degree to which
we're not free
to truly
live authentically truly live in the
moment truly be in the now the present
moment because to truly be in the now is
the ability to respond authentically in
the moment to what is arising rather
than from the conditioned unconscious
responses from our past and so as
children
we are shall we say we're born free you
know you look at a child
yeah a child is you know we're alive
right we're you look into a child's eyes
the child is they're in touch with the
divine they're in touch with their
essence and i think that's where when we
look into a child we melt because we are
reminded of our own divinity we're
reminded of what we were once so what
the hell happens you know we were these
bright beings we would jump on a table
and sing and shout and we didn't care if
we didn't sound like you know mariah
carey or bruno mars we ran naked and we
didn't care like i got a few roles right
uh what do i look like on instagram i'm
not you know slim enough i'm too fat we
were just being letting it all hang out
we pooped when we felt like pooping we
cried when we felt like we were just
being
pure
essential light the light that we were
so what the hell happens that begins
this self-contraction the first thing is
we incarnate into this human experience
we meet our parents they're just doing
the best that they can do based on their
upbringing and their conditioning and
their childhood so we're born into kind
of a preset
uh pattern of conditioning based on
parents based on culture society
religion ancestral patterns and
addictions and conditioning that's been
unresolved so now we're born into this
framework that we're condensed into and
maybe
dad was an alcoholic or mom had mental
health issues or maybe they were
fighting all the time so there was or
maybe they were nice people but they
didn't know how to
meet our emotional needs and so now
and that was painful so now there's some
level of dysfunction trauma or pain that
we experience you know as children and
so often unconsciously because with
these sensitive beings two things happen
the first thing is we begin
to learn how to shut down disconnect and
not feel
as a way of survival the pain that's
going on around in our environment while
it's really painful to not have my needs
met and that really hurts and i feel
helpless so let me just it's too painful
to feel that so let me just numb that
let me shut that down let me disconnect
and so the first thing is all of the
sort of
unprocessed unfelt suppressed emotions
anger pain hurts
we suppress it we suppress it we
suppress it those layers begin building
up and our true authentic light our true
authentic beingness our true authentic
essence
is always there whether we're aware of
it or not it just kind of gets hidden
and clouded underneath the layers of
unprocessed emotion
and now we're wondering well why do i
feel heavy why do i feel depressed and
so we also start learning
a way of being in the world to a defense
mechanism we erect walls in our heart we
we go into our mind become so overly
analytical disconnect from our feelings
our bodies as a way to again not feel
the pain so that that way of
self-protection that we unconsciously
learn in response to what's going on
we then become that version of ourselves
and we hold tightly to that
version of ourselves to survive
to function and ultimately to never
feel that pain
again that holding on becomes a
positionality of control or we we can
call it the ego and we hold on to that
as a way to never feel that pain again
it worked for us when we were five now
we're 10 now we're 20 now we're 25 now
we fall in love and our heart opens and
we're like no i'm never go i'm not going
to open my heart so i don't feel that
helpless or that pain again and so that
self-contraction that we've learned to
become to function and survive we learn
a strategy to get love validation and
approval like who do i need to be in
order to be loved by my dad for me i
thought i needed to be the perfect son
the good one the good boy get all a's
you know take care of everyone take care
of my mother never cry suck it up be
independent and
take over my father's church which we
can get into but but you know we develop
all sorts of roles and masks and
personas
that we present to the world in order to
get love validation and approval so
between avoidance of pain and the
self-defense mechanism that we erect and
the personas and mass that we were we
end up contorting ourselves into a
particular shape we end up controlling
ourselves into a particular condition
construct pattern that we think you see
we are we hold tightly onto that that
gets reinforced by society life goes
around us and we end up holding so
tightly to that that there's no freedom
and we end up thinking this is who we
are we're just basically conditioned
with condition and we hold so tightly
and so
we could say that is ego that's what ego
is the sense of what we identify and
perceive ourselves to be
and the degree to which we're
conditioned the degree to which we're
holding on the degree to which we think
that that's what we are
is the degree to which we're not free
we're not free to love and truly be in
the now and respond from what's what's
really there we're not you know so much
of our potential that we feel inside
gets trapped inside of the pattern in
the prison of our conditioning you know
and so and so
that tends to get reinforced by the life
that we live and that's why
when i unplug people from their typical
life that is reinforcing that pattern of
conditioning
it starts
triggering it starts loosening that grip
that we're used to holding on to for a
sense of
this is me right this is who i am and
and so we have to question so so what
that
stirs in people is
questioning why it's who i am who i
really am like oh this is just who i am
i'm just this way but it's who i am who
i really am or is it just who i've been
conditioned to be and we begin to
realize
that the version of ourselves that we
think we are is really just ego and ego
is not good it's not bad it's just a
vehicle
to function in this lifetime that
yeah it's information yeah exactly so it
leads me to the question of
this attracting
the same pattern of a person to
awaken us to our patterns like when we
when we find ourselves in the same
pattern with the
relationships or with work or whatever
your sort of trauma and your places that
you're more stuck and we attract that we
actually want the opposite but we keep
attracting what our pattern is and can
you explain that sort of
mirroring that happens in life to show
us where we're not free
yeah i think we tend to attract that
energetic pattern because inside of us
is also that incomplete energy and so
with that attraction there's an impulse
inside of us
that is seeking
unconsciously seeking to complete what
is not complete from let's say our
childhood or an old relationship and so
we attract often that energy of what's
incomplete and so let's say in
relationships i like to say that we
attract to us a person
people a person whether it's romantic or
not we attract us a person that tends to
be a mirror manifestation
of ourselves we attract to us a person
that mirrors to us our
unresolved issues our unresolved
patterns
those aspects of ourselves that need to
be integrated faced to be healed to be
released to be forgiven to be let go of
and we attract that person in order to
face those parts of ourselves because
ultimately there is no relationship out
there there's really a relationship out
there that's a projection of our own
consciousness within ourselves and so we
are in relationship
in the seeming form of another person
with ourselves
and so i think when we can really see
that oh [ __ ] it's not really anyone out
there because
what we try to do is we point the finger
out there we make it about the other
person we try to change the other person
and we don't change ourselves ego right
whose job
is to
reinforce our existence ego whose
beautiful job is to keep us safe and
protect us from getting hurt again ego
wants everyone else to change and not to
change we want everyone else to change
and not to change and that is the sort
of self-reinforcing mechanism and
intention of ego uh because the fear of
oh [ __ ] if i change
if i change or my perceived sense of
self change then who will i be and so
change for ourselves which is why we
resist unconsciously and it's a
beautiful intention change feels like a
a death
to who i am you're letting an aspect of
you that you've held on so tightly to
fall
fall away dissolve yeah so rumi said in
order to be free
you must die before you die you know and
i think when we re when we can realize
that we are not that sort of pattern of
conditioning when we can realize well
i'm conditioned i'm not that pattern of
conditioning it's not who i am i'm not
that that what i am is really
beyond that
then
and then as we start to observe that
pattern of conditioning another layer of
freedom starts opening up because as we
can observe that pattern of dance and
conditioning that we are
there's there's a bit of space between
what we perceive ourselves to be and
what we are
and in that space is a tremendous
freedom because then in that space we
have choice
in their space
we can change that that panel of
conditioning but also in that space
when we can observe ourselves doing that
condition dance that sometimes is
self-destructive that sometimes can be
painful
we are able to begin seeing
or hopefully
the underlying
let's say positive intention for the
condition pattern which is survival
which is keeping us safe and for me in
that awareness
empathy can begin rising
like oh
you know oh i'm not sabotaging because
i'm you know i'm an idiot or i'm lazy
i'm not closing my heart and destroying
this relationship necessarily because
i'm a bad person it's like i'm afraid
you know and when we can start seeing
that and shift our relationship to
ourselves in that pattern
and and we can sort of evoke empathy and
compassion within ourselves and then we
can begin holding ourselves right with
that compassion and empathy
that's when
that that sort of defense egoic
mechanism can start relaxing a bit and
that's when opening that's when letting
go that's when surrender can start
happening because
there's a feeling of safety and so it's
really uh like healing is
the willingness to apply loving to those
parts of ourselves that are hurting you
know and that's and that's i think
that's the beginning of healing and so i
think relationships in so many ways
back to your question
uh are a profound mirror to us
of where we are in our own consciousness
the profound feedback mechanism to show
us who we are and where we are and what
needs to be healed you know and i think
that's the gift and and the purpose of
relationship as we hear our souls to
grow and learn and evolve you know so we
can use relationships to just see where
we're at and since we can't change
what's out here and we can't change
what's in here we can start looking at
okay
what what is this person what is this
situation what is this relationship
reflecting to me about myself
what is to show me about myself
you know
how well they meet yeah and something
yeah it's information like some people
say ah that person's out of integrity
that person is a liar that person's this
that person is that you can't change
them but the fact that i'm triggered the
fact that you're triggered is reflecting
something that is incomplete inside of
yourself in some way you see things as
they are we see things as we are exactly
over and over again so i'm very curious
about
relationships um
partly because i've been through a few
and i'm i don't i'm not in one right now
and so they i find them quite
fascinating but with the idea that
especially in an intimate relationship i
mean our family and our intimate
relationships are the things that are
going to trigger us the most
the most they hit the hardest they mean
the most to us they they tap into so
such deep insecurities
and
you know hidden hidden places that we're
holding on to so tightly so
if
those especially in a we you know we
can't change our parents but with a with
a with an intimate relationship if
they're showing us that as a mirror to
show us where we're where we're not
healed i'm very curious if this is
supposed to be something that we
stay with
forever
or if
this is
actually perhaps a flawed
concept
and maybe at some point in time when we
lived to 30 or 40 years old that was
fine but we lived to a hundred now and
so is that the way that we should look
at relationships um because there's such
a perspective on relationships ending as
a failure
yeah i really don't believe that
um
the way we hold relationships now with
this concept of success about being
forever and ever and ever and ever i
think is is a limited
perspective
um because if we understand the real
purpose of life and the real purpose of
relationship we attract someone because
on some level we and that person are a
vibrational match in that particular
moment and there's lessons to learn as
we're talking about in that particular
moment and they're mirroring something
to us in that particular moment of our
evolution so they're a mirror of
ourselves in that moment and so
as souls we incarnate into this human
experience in order to learn to grow to
evolve life is a school in every
relationship and every experience is
part of that curriculum and so if we
really start seeing life as a
evolutionary
process for our souls evolution then we
start understanding
that relationship is one of the
the most um evolutionary quickening
vehicles in the school of life then we
start seeing relationships in a
different context that the purpose of
relationship isn't just to you know feel
good and get unmet needs met and go on
vacation and get some roses and you know
go go go
go swimming together and go to the
movies that the real purpose of
relationship is your evolution the
evolution of your soul and the degree to
which
you
learn
the lessons for why you attracted that
person into your life and the degree to
which you not only learn those lessons
but realize your true nature and become
through the vehicle of that relationship
become the most authentic version of
yourself possible
to me that is the purpose of
relationship so if you understand that
that's the purpose of relationship then
you also won't be shocked or surprised
when [ __ ] comes up because [ __ ] has to
come up that no longer serves from your
shadow from the past from childhood and
everything that is
not love
has to come up everything that is not or
cover all those layers that have been
covering your authentic nature has to
come up in the context and crucible of
relationship in order to be healed in
order to be released in order to be let
go of in order for you to connect more
with what you are and so when [ __ ] comes
up with that understanding
you're able to not run away but you're
able to say okay let me consciously work
through this so i can heal through this
and as i heal through this and learn
this lesson
step more into who i am and be free
and now from that
place of freedom
then that will often affect the other
person because if you're in a joint
dynamic then as you shift either
either they will shift because the
energy is shifted between you or
the previous patterns that used to piss
you off and trigger you
you'll just experience them differently
and or
the dynamic will shift so much and if
the other person doesn't shift then you
will just vibrate and shift out of that
current relationship and so as a result
you will know when a relationship is
complete
when
you've learned the lesson
and
there's no more growth
when you are no longer growing and
evolving together in a similar pace in a
similar vibratory frequency in a similar
direction in a similar energy and you're
growing and let's say the other person
is no longer growing in the same way
and the other person is not willing to
grow also because the willingness is a
key factor
let's just say then
you're no longer in a relationship even
if you are in a relationship
even if you're in the relationship like
we're married but we're not growing
we're not evolving we're not deepening
because the purpose of relationship is
evolution and so even if you are in a
challenging relationship if there's love
there
if there's empathy there
knowing our shit's gonna get triggered
if there's the understanding that we are
here to serve each other souls and we
can do that
compassionately without you know killing
each other we can do that with with
sensitivity because we're holding each
other's hearts so we have that
understanding that this is a yoga
this is a yoga together this is a
spiritual practice
even if difficult things come up then
with that commitment so long as two
people have that commitment to do that
work together even if it's difficult you
have a relationship
and that's how you can keep evolving
together and so long as you're
continuing to evolve and grow together
then there's the possibility to stay
together forever in this lifetime in
this dimension then there's a
possibility but
just because you break up you know i
think there's this idea of oh i broke up
so i failed sometimes your breakup is is
is the graduation is the completion that
you've you've completed your lesson
you've completed your karma you've
completed what you need to learn
and the classroom is done and so let's
let's let's celebrate that you know
let's celebrate the the success of the
intended purpose of that particular
relationship and and i think when we
shift our context then we can allow
relationships to
to be what they're meant to be and we
can allow them to fulfill their highest
destiny without trying to
make something into something that it
necessarily isn't sure sure
and i've also
maybe a perspective i've had as it seems
also like
if you heal a sort of pattern or dynamic
within a relationship
by not reacting in the same way that you
used to
you also don't feed into their need for
your reaction because you are a part of
the puzzle with them and that if you
don't react the way that you used to now
they're not getting what they need
either so it's not just you growing it's
them too it's that they can't see the
pattern and so what i'm hearing you say
is that it's it's not just
a pattern or lesson that you
meet this person to realize and heal
and grow from but you can have
you can have a lifetime of these layers
if there's love and if you're both
committed to doing the work that it
there are enough lessons within that
soul for you to go on and on for a
lifetime is that what you're saying
possibly possibly but not always because
i think some
relationships karmically and some
relationships the purpose
is
a specific purpose
and sometimes that purpose is to serve
you into it's like
graduating from
high school
and
high school was amazing and it's
complete just because high school was
amazing your teacher was amazing your
friends were amazing it doesn't mean
like let's stay in this forever it's
like we're complete now let's go to
university because that's the next
evolution but i but i don't want to go
to university but sometimes that's just
the next evolution so i think some i
think part of it is
we often have from the ego's perspective
we often have this idea of
this has to be the person this has to be
the one right
i've done that so many times i've been
there it's like that we project onto
that person that it's gonna be
what we think it's going to be
and the ego
doesn't really know what it's going to
be but the soul knows the soul has a
deeper intelligence and so i really
believe that
when we can go into relationship and be
be more committed
not just to the person but be more
committed to the evolution and be more
committed to learning the lesson and
growing together and then truly be
because then if you do that no matter
what happens and the outcome
you can never fail no matter what
happens you always win together so long
as you're committed to the evolution
that's that's the first thing and and i
think when we can go into a relationship
and rather than like projecting like
this is what it's going to be
like it's going to be the amount of
times danica i've been in a relationship
fell in love with an amazing woman i'm
like
she's the one i'm gonna make it happen
and it wasn't like i'm like what the
hell happened and now you know and when
it broke up i was heartbroken i was
devastated never going to find love
again
i'm cursed by the universe you know it's
karma from a past life now i look back
at those relationships and i think to
myself
thank god
that didn't work out thank god it didn't
work out but sometimes in the moment
we're not able we're not able to see it
you know so i think some relationships
are meant to serve a very specific
function in our soul's evolutionary
journey
and sometimes that function
is truly only three months
sometimes that you know it's like
sometimes that function is really only a
year to move us to that next phase it's
like you know in sports is not the best
analogy you might have to help me out
here but like
you know i'm not a i grew up in london
so i could put soccer but i think in
american football they have like that
guy who comes on and all he does is like
kicks the field goal kicker yeah yeah
i'm like
that's all he does is just kick that
field goal but he doesn't play anything
no he doesn't throw the ball he no he
just comes on he kicks that's his thumb
that's his entire job so i think there
are some souls
that we have
a connection to that their entire job is
to serve a particular function for us to
see to prepare us for that next level
and that's it
that's it and so i think when we can go
into a relationship in a state of
understanding and openness
then we are more able to
allow
the relationship to be what it is
then i think we'll be more able to allow
the highest
intention
of a relationship
the highest
purpose of that relationship to reveal
itself
and so i think for me
my prayer in relationship with all
relationships romantic or friendship now
is universe i ask for the highest
intention of this relationship to be
revealed
that is that is my request less about i
hope make this the person make this the
one like show me the highest intention
of this relationship and if that is
forever i'm open to that you know and so
i think then we were able to live in
surrender and i think that's when
the true fulfillment of the purpose of
that relationship can blossom and then
we can
it for what it's meant to be
yeah
do you sometimes
do you sometimes get into those prayer
states i'm speaking from my own
experience
oh man do i really mean this this time i
kind of need a break but i'm here for
the highest good of what for my soul's
evolution and you're like oh
it can get so hard it's something
you have those human moments it's hard
it's sometimes hard you know i wrote a
book about surrender
and danica let me tell you when you
write a book about surrender right the
magic of surrender right the universe
kicks you off
and and and and
i have been in an intense crash course
on the new onesies and the angles of
surrender in a way that
i really didn't imagine you know i
really didn't imagine and it's been very
humbling it's been really humbling can
you share some do you have some examples
wow yeah like like i was writing the
book in 2019 before covert
before code so i'm like yeah i'm gonna
write this book on surrender well first
it wasn't the book i wanted to write
and i had an agenda to write no no no no
no i had to
yeah
exactly and so right as i'm finishing
the book
it's like bam
and so here i am being on the road you
know 150 60 days a year uh doing events
boom entire business shutdown like for
many of us but being on the road my
entire business shut down boom grounded
to a halt
lifestyle everything everybody
everything everything and everything i
put my you know like life and purpose
and just heart and soul everything this
was it and so boom okay brought me to my
knees i was in the late for 20 years
late was my like
my i was late through and through my
identity was l.a um
let go of my office in l.a was
heartbreaking let go of my apartment in
l.a couldn't imagine not living in l.a i
had a house in phoenix
a small house in
phoenix are you yeah and so i had a
house there for like a couple of years
that i didn't know why i was buying this
place but i would go there once a month
for a week do some writing so i
basically moved to phoenix which was a
bit of a culture shock from l.a it is
i'll help you out
we should grab coffee
but it gets better because i was in
phoenix uh so so it felt like i was
uprooted from everything i knew uh here
i'm in phoenix no no one and then
full madly in love with the woman i
thought i was going to marry and be with
and had visions in the cosmos and the
universe and downloads like this is her
we were together boom six months later
over
brings me to my knees like i you know
brings me to my knees so that prayer
about the highest good you're talking
about okay the highest good but hey wait
a second this isn't the highest bidder i
had intended you know
if it felt terrible in the moment um so
so humbling because it was like the
universe saying again
you thought you knew
that you don't you thought you were in
control but you've never been life has
always been and so it was a really
profound humbling moment again and so
here i'm in phoenix thinking okay i'm
going to camp out in phoenix
now i get this calling to go visit miami
just just uh go visit for five days cut
a long story short i end up in miami end
up going back to miami i end up selling
my house i end up being guided to sell
my house in phoenix boom and moving to
miami boom now i think i think i'm
getting this together you know the
surrender thing i'm gonna live in miami
it's a new start new energy miami's
popping is happening miami all the way
now i'm in miami for a year a year later
my lease is up i feel the strong
guidance leave miami back to l.a so i do
this full circle then it gets all the
way back to l.a
in within two years and it just felt
like you know my team members shifting
my assistance shifting all of these
things happening that brings me right
back to the beginning and it just felt
like
a profound surrender and so
yeah yeah oh that's crazy i it reminds
me of the book the alchemist and
my takeaway from the book the alchemist
have you read that
is it
is exactly that is that we think that
our life should be this linear
this is some some kind of linear
experience where one thing leads to the
next but really in the book it showed me
how
a to b
actually takes
all the way around to get there
because it's still the fastest way
because you had to know all of that to
get to the next step
and so
so it sounds like that was what happened
it was
you know i think the the lessons and the
evolution
that i went through
along the way
you know to me it's who we become in the
process and so the evolution
and the lessons in the deepening within
myself i realized was the necessary
preparation
for
the next level of my purpose
that i couldn't have
i couldn't have gone through an
evolution unless i went through those uh
intense sort of stripping away and so
what is that then what is that
was it finishing the book is it
something else what is that
i mean
i i i i can't realize about yourself you
know i
in so many ways it was just it was
another level of surrender and it was
another level of
because i think the next level of our
lives the next level of our purpose
requires the next level of us
which
means we have to let go
of who we've been
and who we've been has served us to this
it's a death who we've been has served
us to this moment
but i think to truly
you know when i look at the great ones
and i think we all have the capacity for
that
mandela and martin luther king and
gandhi you know we all have that
capacity they showed us the possibility
and when i look at them they all
surrendered themselves so completely to
life
and being used by life
that in their surrender they transcended
themselves
and life
began to manifest through them life
began to use them life began to speak
through them and through that life did
the work through them as vehicles you
know and maybe they had no idea what was
going to unfold but life knew and life
had that intelligence and so for me
i feel that
preparation for that next level which
i'll be honest i you know have senses of
what that is going to be
uh
but not completely and so i think for
the first time in my life
i am really embracing
not knowing
you know that doesn't mean i'm sitting
there doing nothing you know but i'm
really just embracing like
i don't know but i'm completely like my
prayer now danica is
universe i am open and available to
being
used and of service for the highest good
i'm open to being like use me for the
service of the highest good of humanity
and
and and it's become less about
okay this is what i want
this is what i want here are my goals
and it's become more about
feeling
what is
life what is the divine what is the
universe what is
what is the deepest impulse of what life
is seeking to express through me now
what is the deepest impulse of what life
is seeking to manifest through me now
and doing my best to
attune to that and feel that and and
align
put my personality
with this movement of what life is
seeking to express you know and it's
it's
i have senses i have definitely feelings
and so
i think when we surrender
in that way
we transcend ourselves and i think when
we do that we transcend our personal
power we transcend our egos we tap into
another dimension of life another
dimension
of the universe and
like that's when we tap the magic and
life begins to
live us more life begins to move through
life begins to manifest to us more and i
think that's when miracles can kind of
happen well
the name of the book is the magic of
surrender so that's when the magic
happens but like this is something that
just came to mind i see things kind of
visually um but it's almost like when we
are who we think we're supposed to be we
can only be that one thing and we're not
that we are not able to
we're only that we walk through life in
a silo that is not as impactful but when
we dissolve the ideas of what we think
we're supposed to be
we now actually become a portal
for
for more people to work through us and
be affected in a positive way
and we can
we have that sort of like it's almost
like we can create alchemy with people
where when we think we're one thing we
are only that one thing and it's a
narrow existence but when we get rid of
that now we can be everything for
everybody and it's so much bigger
yeah yeah i think
you know in in the surrender like
there's this idea that if we truly
surrender
giving up we're
going to be taking advantage of we won't
manifest our goals dreams a limited idea
of what we think we're going to live our
goals dreams and desires but you know
what i'm feeling and seeing in my own
life and what i've what i've seen and
experienced with those around me is when
we surrender
what if we got more
you know like surrender is to really
like take the limits off of life because
from the perspective of the mind and the
personality and the ego
we're only able to see a very limited
perspective of the tapestry of life and
the possibilities of life and it's like
looking at a painting but we're seeing
the corner of the painting but we don't
see the whole painting itself and and so
many times from the perspective of the
ego and the eye like what do i want
uh what we think we want
is just what we think we want based on
who we think we are
and it's limited and so sometimes we get
what we think we want we manifest what
we thought we wanted from the level of
the ego
only to be dissatisfied and and so i
think when we truly take the limits off
of life then we're then we're available
then we're open then we're not holding
on like it has to be this i have to be
that so i think it's part of surrender
is is like if you surrender what if you
got what if you got more what if you got
more than you could even
imagine for yourself what if you got
more than you could even
visualize and and and
contextualize and write in your journal
like to me life is bigger than us you
know and so things can flow so fast too
like when you get out of the way of your
ideas and you are in alignment
i don't know about you but i i've had so
many experiences where all of a sudden
plans will change to make my life better
in simple ways that i could have never
done like people canceling something so
that i could do this other thing or
things that i could have never arranged
and you're like and they can happen on
this level and they can also happen on
really macro levels that affect your
entire life and your trajectory
um but can you explain the energetics of
that grasping and of that um
uh attachment
and the pat like we're talking about the
power of the surrender but i want to go
into the other side of it to understand
what it feels like when you're not
surrendering
what what's happening why because i mean
i've had experiences again
um where i'll
want something even something kind of
simple like oh just oh i wonder if this
person's going to call me or something
and then all of a sudden i let go and
not like oh well but like i truly in my
heart i feel it and i'm like they're
probably busy it's not a big deal i'll
hear from them and then all of a sudden
like the it just
boom i hear from them right away i mean
that's just a simple silly example
but this sort of grasping at something
and when you truly let go just can you
explain the energy yeah
i i think the grasping
you know we kind of touched on it but
comes from that egoic sense right and
the ego
is seeking a perceived sense of self to
keep us safe to avoid pain and so
there's this idea
that we mistakenly have
that if our ego if i can
control my feelings control how you
perceive me if i can control every
thing
then i'm gonna be safe
then i won't get hurt again which is why
we grasp which is why we tend to to
control everything because it's
beautiful in tension but it's it's it's
gonna drive us crazy anxiety frustration
fear and so in that grasping is
tightness in that grasping this
contraction is like in that grasping is
imagine you just go through life holding
your breath you know and you're
spiritually constipated so to speak and
you're just holding on it's like
life can't flow
energy can't flow the universe can't
flow and so blessings might come through
energetically but you know they're kind
of like a stone they would just bounce
off of you versus just
being open and so i think when we let go
of that grasping
and we're available
and we're open
to me part of success
is not just about hard work with a
closed fist but it's about openness and
availability because when we're open and
available
energy floats energy circulates life is
able to flow then we're also in a much
more
available state
a receptive energetic state to receive
you know when we're grasping and holding
on we'll come from the standpoint of
force not flow and when we're in force
it's like we're trying to make something
happen that may not be
what it's meant to be and trying to make
something into something that it's not
doesn't make it so and so when we're
holding on
and gripping tightly
trying to make something into something
but life might be trying to take us in a
different direction
and so when we're holding on so tightly
sometimes we end up
missing the flow of where life is going
because we're so busy holding on to that
rock when the river's already going that
way so so part of surrender is taking
the limits off part of surrender was
allowing part of surrender availability
part of surrender was the openness to
say okay well
to allow i think when we let go of that
grasping of who we think we should be
often based on our conditioning and the
way we think our life should be
based on our conditioning and many of
our goals are sometimes projections
of unmet needs from our childhood you
know and so when we let go of that
graspy totally
ben would like then we can allow them
the energy of life
that is authentically moving then we can
allow the authentic movement of life of
what our life is seeking to be that
intelligence that's inside that knows
then then we can allow what life is
authentically seeking to reveal to
unfold
and
there is
an innate intelligence inside of us
it's inside of us already there's that
that is
let's just talk biologically for a
second let's not even be spiritual just
cut your finger
yeah
something i don't whatever you want to
call it that innate intelligence
it knows how to heal
yeah you and i we we don't have to sit
here oh cut my finger [ __ ] down i could
cut my finger i got to pray about it got
to do some special mantra got to do some
visualization i have to be a good person
you could be pablo escobar el chapo it
doesn't matter you don't have to be
mother teresa just cut your finger the
innate intelligence life
knows how to heal
and so i think
we're kind of disconnected from that you
know we've forgotten that we've gotten
so busy distracted condition that we've
lost touch with
this innate intelligence that's inside
of us and we've begun to override it so
i think if we can just even
bring ourselves back into relationship
to the body
and just just simply
maybe just start by feeling the breath
like
sounds simple basic but
what is that like we're having this
conversation
and you're you and i we're not sitting
here all those listening we're not
sitting here going
i have to breathe i have to like active
i have to really i have to breathe
really i have to breathe
it's just happening in spite of us
there's an effortlessness
to the breath
that is happening
you know you ate this morning or this
afternoon lunch breakfast and
something is digesting your food
and there is an intelligence this innate
intelligence there are trillions and
trillions and trillions and trillions
and trillions of cells in your body
that are interacting and synchronizing
and coordinating and mitochondria and
eyes and liver and
it's all just it's all
happening
in spite of us
you know
and
we don't trust life we don't trust that
that that thing that is like there's a
thing whatever god
there's an energy
that is functioning you
me
eight billion people
the cockroaches the tigers the giraffes
the birds all of existence that you know
it's just
it's happening
without you
it's just unfolding the sun and the
stars so i think if we can just
kind of be still and bring ourselves
into relationship with
the breath and go just like sit with
that like
what is breathing right now you know
just even just meditating because when
we do when i know what i do
it's mind blowing
like something is
is is
alive and to me that innate intelligence
is
the rhythm of life you know that innate
intelligence is unfolding life my father
was a really great he is a great man
would say to me when i was a kid when i
would stress and worry a lot as a child
he would say to me
son why why are you worrying so much
about everything you want about all
these things all these things why are
you worrying so much he would say did
you bring yourself here
where did you bring yourself to this
planet did you bring yourself
to this existence and i would say well
no i just showed up here and he said
exactly
so
do you not think that whatever it is
that brought you here
that it the intelligence
does it not know how to unfold you did
the trees struggle did the fruit
struggle did the does the grass struggle
to grow like did they no so why do you
stress and so i think we
kind of trust
like i was joking to someone the other
day like we trust siri more than we
trust this intelligence you know and
and yet
if we just if we just observe ourselves
and we just observe the nature of life
like this i'm looking at trees and i'm
looking at the sky i'm looking at the
sun it's like holy [ __ ] like it's
amazing yeah but it is but we don't pay
attention to it so what is this
awareness to being aware
that we're experiencing
if we're just energy and
in we're kind of
reacting to patterns
what gives us like basically i'm getting
to consciousness like yeah and i'm
curious about my
my most seeking question in life that i
get curious about every single day
is i'm like what is reality like what
are we
what is consciousness why am i able to
be aware that i'm having thoughts
like what is that next tier and i was
also a little confused because
i'm guessing you believe in
reincarnation
or not i believe in reincarnation you
know that's it
and that we have to have a then that we
didn't choose like you're you're
hearing the story about your dad and
about um did you choose to come here
it's like i'm curious
about this sort of like package of
consciousness reality and
uh evolution of souls or reincarnation
possibly
it where does that all fall like what
what do you think of first when i
mention all those things you know first
i'll just say
you know i have had experiences where
i've been certain places
and i felt like i have been here before
you know and it's like oh i've been here
before i've been here before i've been
here before i was in egypt been here
before i was in japan my mother's
japanese been here before you know in
brazil definitely been here before
mexico been here before and so i think
it felt like wow if there was such a
thing as past lives and i've been here
before but can i prove it
no i can't i can't prove it i mean it's
it's a concept it's an idea that
i can let's say
hold and play with
that might serve a moment
within my consciousness in a moment
but i'm not necessarily attached to the
idea that i am reincarnated you know and
i was let's say
you know
king tune carmen in the past life
because like this you know everybody
believes they're too common and when you
talk about reincarnation what what does
no one ever say like yeah i was a trash
collector in the box of course yeah
exactly like every shaman tells you or
some like queer
king
and so
i i've had these experiences but i'm not
so necessarily attached to
that it's real
you know i i think
on some level we are all consciousness
and at that level
we are all one so at that level i think
we all have the experience
of experiencing at the deepest level
ourselves as everything
and so i think it's possible
that's our yes yes i think at that
deepest level because that we are all
that awareness itself that one
consciousness
that
there might be and i'm not saying this
is true there might be moments when we
experience i was too in common
it's possible
that someone else might experience so i
was too in common
but it's being filtered through the ego
personality that we then hold on to
but it can't be like two people were too
uncommon but that one consciousness was
manifesting as that toon common that
when you might have a flashback it's
just two
seemingly individual personalities are
tapping into the experience of that one
consciousness does that make sense yeah
that aspect of consciousness is
and so like there can't be 500 elvis
presley's but they're but but
consciousness experience because for me
this whole thing really all of life is a
manifestation of consciousness life to
me is the manifestation of consciousness
expressing in the multiplicity of form
and so ultimately
the experience for me is all of this is
really a one woman one-man
one-person show
and when
it's a one meaning as so one being one
one energy
one conscious one consciousness
manifesting as me as you as biden as
donald trump as putin as you know
ukrainian president as the congolese kid
as margaret thatcher one consciousness
playing all characters in this maya
illusion play of life in this apparent
play in this simulation of life is one
consciousness playing all of the roles
simultaneously as itself experiencing
itself and so now as these characters
like it seems like that we are separate
beings in this simulation and play and
we seem to take it separately but i
think part of two things when the body
drops and we
this character dice
then the curtain gets pulled back we
take off the mask and then ah we
realized ah there was only one of us
really here or we wake up some people
might call it enlightened liberation we
wake up in this lifetime and go
oh
there's not really a danica over there
and there's not really a crew over here
there's just the apparent manifestation
of consciousness playing danica i'm
playing too but really what is that what
what is looking out of those eyes and
these eyes is really the same
consciousness rising and at the deepest
level there's a shared being that is one
and i think as we loosen that it go with
grip then we tap into that deeper
dimension and access to the inherent
oneness of all existence and the more we
do that the more free we
the more freedom we access that is
always present and the more love there
is because i think part of love is that
recognition of that
sheer oneness that we are that there
really is no separation and i think that
really essentially on some level is the
process of life
and the game that we're in to awaken in
this play and so when i think
when all what when the
when life is over and the current is
pulled back
and all the characters take off their
masks and we see like oh [ __ ]
it was just one this is one one-man show
it was a one-woman show conscious was
playing all the characters and you
realize that the
the officer goes to the divine the oscar
goes that the greatest performer
of all existence was
source energy consciousness you know and
i think
that
to me
is is is
is the freedom and what we're here to
awaken to you know and so
i forget your first question
no you're answering them all i keep
thinking of questions and you keep
answering it because what i really want
to boil it down to because some of these
are big questions that we really can't
know
we might be able to kind of come to a no
wing within us and what we feel to be
true but we're not going to find proof
of this i don't think this isn't part of
the human experience i think that's part
of the mystery of being human that's
what makes this experience valuable and
why we um why as a as a as an existence
as a human race like why we're so
interesting because we don't know and
that free will really gives us
the choice and within the choice we now
um can change that perception that
sources are experiencing through us
which is so powerful
but the ultimate real question is like
you know
what is this all for
what what why would that why would
why would source want to experience
itself
in so many different aspects what's the
end game
for
that
i don't even know if i if i if i can
even answer that if i have words for
that
you know my simplest answer is i have no
idea i have no idea you know i think why
not
for the play of it yes what what
for the player
to play
you know when you look at the word play
to play as a child right to play
but then you go to the theater to see it
play
and it's and i think
you realize that this is a cosmic play
being played
and so
why not for the player for the play of
consciousness that is unfolding you know
why why not
so then what's your what's your advice
if this is the if this is the truth at
uh completely
at the singularity level at the highest
level of macro
what is your advice to
all of us
to how to
step into that
and how to live our life and what are
some steps we can take you know one
thing that's helped me a bit is
i used to look at life
and
[Music]
you know life is hard
life is life will beat you up and life
is challenging and there's war and
there's you know
destruction and you look at the world
it's like all this [ __ ] in the world and
what is this craziness and so
um
i think for me what helped me is just
understanding that this
dimension
is a three-dimensional realm of duality
and this dimension
is a world of interdependent polaric
opposites
that
is the nature of life
in this dimension is the 3d
interdependent polarity opposite
yin yang up down good bad male female
light dark you know left right rich poor
this domain
is that
and when you can accept that this domain
is that it's not meant to be
i don't think it's meant to be an
ultimate blissful eternal utopia in this
domain a transcendental domain that's
not why we incarnate into this
you know level of the simulation to
experience that and so when we can
accept the three-dimensional dualistic
nature of this domain and stop looking
for perfection here yes stop looking for
perfection here utopia here it's like
there's always going to be war and
duality it's the bow you know in that
down there's the black and the white dot
the white and the black dot
it's all contained in this domain so
when we can just accept it for what it
is
that we incarnate into this
dimension
of existence
that is limitation
in order to to to enter limitation
the fraction of life
the experiences of life
so that
we can remember at the game the video
game remember access the freedom
of our being inside of this to me that
is part of that purpose to to enter
limitation to experience and awaken to
the
unlimited
that is within us and through limitation
remember what we truly are in the
limitation
to me
that's the freedom and so when we can
embrace this for what it is
then we don't resist what it is we don't
fight what it is we don't expect it to
be different we don't
we judge less we just embrace what it is
more
and then i think we realize that the
true source of wholeness and perfection
and bliss and transcendental you know
awakening
is not out here it's in here it's within
us it's in the depth of our being
and
life forces us to access like the
kingdom of heaven
is within
jesus said it don't take you for the
kingdom of heaven
is within he didn't say the kingdom of
heaven is you know in a lamborghini or
in beverly hills it's within you
is there anything i can do you can do he
said too anything i can do
you can do that and more and more and so
i think he just showed us that that
christ consciousness was available
within us and that's where we can then
access heaven on earth within ourselves
and so i think when we can
embrace that the way of the nature of
this reality
then we start freeing ourselves in this
reality to access that inner freedom
within ourselves and i think if you look
at even the last couple of years that
have been challenging
for many of us
um
i think all of it is the the universal
impulse pushing us
and and challenging us to crack open to
let go of all those places we've held on
to for a sense of freedom out here
to go deeper to access the source of
freedom inside so that when we go into
the world
we can be free
realizing that
freedom is not something you get or
retained freedom is what you are it's
your being and to me that
that's kind of why we're here you know
and so don't look through it out here
look through it inside is what i would
say
i think that's where they say like mic
drop that was
so well said i can't think of a better
way to end it honestly thank you that
was
i agree and i i think that's that's a
that's a beautiful perspective um
and so we should all go play now
yes play you know that's that's really
when i got it's like this is a play
let's play and let's
let's not take it like take it seriously
like when when we go to the movies we
take it seriously we do like we go we
watch you know uh tom cruise or you know
uh denzel or whoever we watch them we
take it seriously
but we don't take it seriously
but we take it seriously but we don't
take it seriously you know and so i
think that's grateful for that duality
we should be grateful for that paradox
because it's in for again it's it's
information like the mirroring the the
the duality the the the light the dark
the good the bad the joyful the
miserable it's information
and how to grow
oh my gosh thank you so much i'm so glad
that i'm so glad that nina introduced me
to you and i'm so glad that we did this
interview and um you're gonna
continue to inspire so so many people
only at an increasingly um
faster rate all the time i believe
because your message is so clear
and so apparent
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button